Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
你好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
挑战中还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to this first ever Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am hoping that you're going to find this a really useful resource. So I am a clinical psychologist and I know that in your position, when it was my time to be an aspiring clinical psychologist, that I would have found this really useful. So I hope you do too, but please do feel free to get in contact with me and shape this you know make this what you want um so i'm aiming that the podcasts are all going to be um you know similar length um not any longer really than than 20 minutes unless i've got interviews happening often as short as sort of 10 minutes um but they're not scripted um I've got ideas of what I will be talking about, but I'm going to be drawing on current themes in psychology and thinking about,
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南吧。我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听首期《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是Marianne Trent博士，希望你能从中获得真正有用的资源。我是一名临床心理学家，我知道在你的位置上，当我也曾是一名有抱负的临床心理学家时，我会觉得这非常有帮助。所以我希望你也能觉得有用，请随时与我联系，并塑造这个节目，让它成为你想要的样子。我的目标是让每期播客的长度保持在20分钟以内，除非有采访，否则通常短至10分钟左右。节目没有剧本，我有一些想谈论的想法，但我会借鉴心理学领域的热门话题，并思考……
you know, current events and also issues are really pertinent to you as an aspiring psychologist. So who are you? You know, in my mind, you are quite possibly already graduated in your undergraduate psychology degree. And, you know, you are maybe working in some kind of relevant industry trying to gain some experience or you may be you know as I have been in the past you may be in something that doesn't feel terrifically relevant so I worked for quite a long time at Argos head office so I'm originally from the Milton Keynes area and that is where you could find me having a lovely time with my colleagues doing my job very well but actually punching into that phone system at you know 8.59am, seeing that clock tick over to 9am and thinking, oh dear lord, I cannot wait to see that clock say 5pm so I can punch out again. So I feel like I've always had the ability to make the most of whatever situation that I find myself in. So I did, you know, there are aspects of that job that I really enjoyed.
你知道，当前的事件以及对你作为一名有抱负的心理学家来说真正相关的问题。那么你是谁呢？在我看来，你很可能已经获得了心理学本科学位。而且，你可能正在某个相关行业工作，试图积累经验；或者你可能像我过去一样，身处一个感觉不太相关的行业。我曾在Argos总部工作了很长时间，我来自米尔顿凯恩斯地区，那时我会在那里和同事们愉快地工作，表现也很出色。但实际上，在早上8点59分打卡进入电话系统，看着时钟跳到9点，心里想着：天哪，我真等不及看到时钟指向下午5点，这样我就能再次打卡下班了。所以我感觉自己总是有能力在任何情况下都做到最好。所以，那份工作中确实有一些我非常喜欢的地方。
And it certainly showed me, you know, really useful skills about how to do the customer service role, but for stores. And so in stores are having a hard time or needed problems with, you know, stock or sorting something out, they would call me. I can't even remember what the team was called. It was a while ago. But, you know, I was decent at the job. I got good feedback from my managers and, you know, popular with my team. And, you know, the ability to play office chair Olympics was definitely around when the phone lines were quieter. So, you know, I made the most of it. And also at that time, Argos head office had free vend on their drinks vending machine and their hot chocolate was really rather good and also their vegetable soup and chicken soup was pretty good too so I'd often have a hot
它确实教会了我关于如何做好客户服务角色的非常有用的技能。当时如果门店遇到困难，或者在库存或处理问题上需要帮助，他们就会打电话给我。我甚至不记得那个团队叫什么名字了，那是很久以前的事了。但我工作做得不错，从经理那里得到了很好的反馈，在团队中也很受欢迎。而且，当电话线路比较安静时，我们绝对会玩“办公椅奥林匹克”。所以，我充分利用了那段时光。而且当时Argos总部的自动售货机是免费的，他们的热巧克力非常好喝，蔬菜汤和鸡汤也很不错，所以我经常在10点左右喝一杯……
chocolate or a little cup of soup um you know around 10 o'clock and I used to like a late lunch I used to like a late lunch I'd go to um lunch about two o'clock because of course if you've ever worked in a phone or customer service call center you have to stagger your lunches um because you need to make sure there's always enough people um to be able to answer the phone so I'd nominate myself to have a late lunch which would be two till three um and then I'd get back and I'd only have two hours left winning I think I also got a tea break um I think the breaks weren't paid I can't remember but um you know I had great fun and actually got really lovely memories of the day that um one of my managers wound up one of my friends who had C's, S's and T's in his name and actually prized off the keys and swapped them around because she knew that his typing wasn't that brilliant. And so every time he
热巧克力或一小杯汤。我以前喜欢晚一点吃午饭，大约两点钟去吃。因为如果你在电话或客户服务呼叫中心工作过，你就必须错开午餐时间，以确保总有足够的人手来接听电话。所以我自告奋勇吃晚午餐，时间是两点到三点，回来后就只剩下两个小时了，我觉得这很划算。我想我还有茶歇时间，我不记得休息时间是否带薪了，但那段时光真的很有趣。我至今还记得有一天，我的一位经理捉弄了我的一位朋友，他的名字里有C、S和T，她把键盘上的这些键撬下来换了位置，因为她知道他的打字水平不太好。所以每次他……
typed his name at the end of a note that he'd recorded for a client call, it was wrong. So his name, I'm going to tell you you his name was Chris Arnott but it couldn't work out why every time he typed his name it was coming out as Crit Arnott and it still makes me smile to this day I still speak I still think about you Crit Arnott yeah so absolutely I think there's learning to make hay while the sun shines, as they say. So even if you're not in an industry that feels that relevant, it is important to think about how you can turn it to your advantage. How you can, you know, perhaps ask for some more responsibility. So I recognised actually, you know, my skills were perhaps a little bit above, you know, I wasn't firing on all cylinders, I wasn't using all of my
在记录客户通话的笔记末尾输入名字时，总是打错。他的名字是Chris Arnott，但他搞不懂为什么每次打名字都会变成Crit Arnott。这件事至今仍让我忍俊不禁，我还会想起你，Crit Arnott。是的，我认为正如人们所说，要学会“趁热打铁”。所以，即使你身处的行业感觉不那么相关，思考如何将其转化为你的优势也很重要。你可以尝试争取更多的责任。我意识到，我的技能可能比那个角色要求的要高一点，我并没有全力以赴，没有发挥出我所有的……
brain power in that role. And so I asked to have additional responsibilities of looking at the data for the calls and for looking at you know the data for the staff on duty and actually you know it meant that I was able to punch out of that phone system which meant that I was less traceable as well in my own data so when the manager was doing the data, you'd get things in your inbox saying that you'd been logged in for how many minutes and what your average call length was and how much gaps you were having between calls. But when I took on all this extra juicy, it actually meant that my data was completely bunkum it didn't make any sense because of course I wasn't logged in for large portions which skewed the data and so it meant my manager didn't really know what I was up to even though it was a shared office so they could see what I was doing but
脑力。所以我申请承担额外的责任，比如查看通话数据和值班人员数据。实际上，这意味着我能够从电话系统中注销，这让我在自己的数据中也没那么容易被追踪。当经理处理数据时，你的收件箱会收到通知，显示你登录了多少分钟、平均通话时长是多少，以及通话间隔有多长。但当我承担了这些额外的工作后，我的数据就完全乱套了，根本说不通，因为我在很大程度上没有登录，这扭曲了数据。所以我的经理并不知道我在做什么，尽管我们在同一个办公室，他们能看到我的行为，但……
it just allowed me to take my foot off that gas pedal you know a little bit and to find a little bit of breathing room. And, you know, those of you who are listening to this, you may find that you are in a really highly demanding role. So you might be, you know, perhaps in an IAPT service or something like that. You might have real, real high demands on your time and it's really hard to catch that breathing space. But you might still, regardless of your role, be able to think about how you could use your unique skills and talents, even if it is a relevant psychology role that you're working in to really, you know, be able to help yourself stand out and to help you to gain that relevant experience so this was supposed to be an introduction to the podcast and to to me and why
这让我能够稍微松一口气，找到一点喘息的空间。你们中正在听这期节目的人，可能发现自己正处于一个要求极高的岗位上。你可能在IAPT（心理治疗改善获取）服务机构工作，时间压力非常大，很难获得喘息空间。但无论你的角色如何，你仍然可以思考如何利用自己独特的技能和天赋，即使是在相关的心理学岗位上，也能让自己脱颖而出，获得宝贵的经验。这本应是对播客和我的介绍，以及为什么……
you might want to listen and already I can't help myself but share information with you so let me give you a typical day for someone that had contacted me recently. Because, you know, this shows us just what jobs you might be applying to, or what jobs you might be doing currently, whilst trying to further your career in psychology. 9am, an appointment which was complex, so finished at 10.30. 10.30, notes for that appointment. 11am, an appointment, so that would be a client appointment. 12pm, my manager wanted to talk about a supervisee who's on sick leave, 12.30, my own line management with another supervisee, 1pm supervision with another supervisee, 2 o'clock, same as above, 3pm personal counselling and 4.30 line management with a supervisee. And in the background, there was occupational health policy and stuff for looking after the well-being of this person's team
你可能想听这个节目，但我已经忍不住要和你分享信息了。让我给你讲讲最近联系我的人的典型一天。因为这展示了你可能正在申请什么样的工作，或者在追求心理学职业生涯的同时正在做什么样的工作。上午9点，一个复杂的预约，10点半结束。10点半，整理预约笔记。上午11点，一个预约，那是客户预约。中午12点，经理要谈论一位请病假的督导对象。12点半，与另一位督导对象的个人管理。下午1点，与另一位督导对象的督导。2点，同上。3点，个人咨询。4点半，与督导对象进行管理沟通。在后台，还有职业健康政策以及照顾该团队成员福祉的相关事务。
it's a busy job you know we are absolutely in the health service asking a lot of people working in you know in roles who are aspiring psychologists. So, of course, we know that as an aspiring psychologist, you do have unique skills and talents. But it's also important that we make sure that we're not being asked to work outside of our competencies. You know, anybody in that kind of demanding role would find that, you know, quite an ask, you know, even me, in my role as a qualified psychologist, would find that a pretty demanding day. So when I was in the NHS, I was able to structure my own time in my most recent job. So I'd manage my own diary so long as I was able to demonstrate that I was obviously seeing, you know, the number of clients per week and had enough clients on my caseload, but to kind of achieve 50% face to face time. So that's often
这是一份忙碌的工作。在医疗服务领域，我们确实对那些有抱负的心理学家提出了很高的要求。当然，我们知道作为一名有抱负的心理学家，你拥有独特的技能和天赋。但同样重要的是，我们要确保自己没有被要求在能力范围之外工作。任何处于这种高要求岗位的人都会觉得这相当吃力，即使是我，作为一名合格的心理学家，也会觉得那是非常辛苦的一天。所以当我在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）工作时，在最近的一份工作中，我能够安排自己的时间。只要我能证明我每周确实见到了足够数量的客户，并且有足够的个案量，达到50%的面谈时间，我就能管理自己的日程。这通常……
quite common. But I know that across the country roles more junior than mine are being expected to have a much higher face-to-face ratio but that's really challenging and we have to think about at what cost to you as an individual, you know, because actually, you know, one of my favourite things about my job is the ability to hold people in mind and to have, you know, those random moments of connection where I'll be, you know, doing something like some paperwork or writing up the notes or I might even be, you know, off duty chopping carrots for my children if you are a parent is it just me who seems to be perpetually peeling carrots and chopping peppers my children are not big vegetable eaters but one of them likes carrots and one of them likes peppers
很常见。但我知道在全国范围内，比我级别低的岗位被要求有更高的面谈比例，这真的很有挑战性。我们必须思考这对你个人来说代价是什么，因为我工作中我最喜欢的事情之一，就是能够把人们放在心上，并拥有那些随机的连接时刻。比如我正在做文书工作或写笔记，或者我可能在下班后为孩子们切胡萝卜。如果你是父母，是不是只有我一个人似乎永远在削胡萝卜和切辣椒？我的孩子们不太爱吃蔬菜，但其中一个喜欢胡萝卜，另一个喜欢辣椒。
I feel like it's just a constant groundhog day. If you've got any other advice for vegetables that are tolerated by children, also feel free to fling them at my way. So yeah, these are demanding roles. And actually, whilst chopping these carrots and peppers, I don't have to use my full brain capacity. I probably should as I might chop a finger off. But you know, I like the flexibility and the time and space that it gives me to be able to think about clients. So you know, if I'm out on a run, and I see someone, and it reminds me of something we've spoken about, you know, in a session, I like the ability to be able to join up the dots and to reflect on my client. And I actually do often tell my clients when I have done that.
我觉得这就像永无止境的“土拨鼠日”。如果你还有其他孩子们能接受的蔬菜建议，也请随时告诉我。所以，这些都是高要求的角色。实际上，在切这些胡萝卜和辣椒时，我不需要动用全部脑力。我可能应该小心点，否则可能会切到手指。但我喜欢这种灵活性，以及它给我的时间和空间，让我能够思考客户的情况。所以，如果我在跑步时看到某个人，让我想起了我们在会谈中讨论过的事情，我喜欢能够把这些点连接起来并反思我的客户。我确实经常在这样做之后告诉我的客户。
And especially if I've been in supervision, sometimes I tell the client that I have spoken about them in supervision, but I tell them that, you know, that's not unique to them. This isn't me saying I can't do this work. It isn't me saying I don't know what to do. We're thinking about it as it being about, you know, trying to really advance this work to make it more optimal and thinking about actually for my own professional development, it is a requirement that I am supervised by somebody more senior and more experienced than myself. So I hope that's useful for you. And please, if you do want any more examples about how I talk to clients about certain things, do let me know and we can shape a podcast episode around that so before we finish for today I thought I
特别是如果我参加了督导，有时我会告诉客户我已经在督导中讨论过他们了，但我会告诉他们，这并不是他们独有的。这不是说我无法完成这项工作，也不是说我不知道该怎么做。我们认为这是为了真正推进这项工作，使其达到最优状态。考虑到我自己的专业发展，我必须接受比我资深、经验比我丰富的人的督导。所以我希望这对你有用。如果你想要更多关于我如何与客户讨论某些事情的例子，请告诉我，我们可以围绕那个主题制作一期播客。
would tell you a little bit more about myself so you do know now that I'm Dr Marianne Trent clinical psychologist and have also worked in Argos head office but clearly I didn't get to be a clinical psychologist just from working in Argos head office. So I qualified in 2011 so my training started at a university in the Midlands in 2008. So I was filling out my declensi form for the clearinghouse programs in 2007 and I speak to you as the right now as the process for the 2021 forward slash 2022 applications are open so it's application season so application fever if you are looking for any support or guidance in how to complete your form, then do check out my YouTube videos on good thinking psychological services. And there are a series of live Q&A videos that I did in September this year, so 2021. And I also did some in the application season last year, so the 2020 season as well. So do check those out. And also, I am the lead author of the Clinical Psychologist
在今天结束之前，我想多介绍一下我自己。你现在知道我是临床心理学家Marianne Trent博士，也曾在Argos总部工作过，但显然我不是仅仅通过在Argos总部工作就成为临床心理学家的。我在2011年获得资格，我的培训于2008年在中部地区的一所大学开始。所以我在2007年填写了清算所（Clearinghouse）项目的申请表。我现在向你讲话时，2021/2022年度的申请流程已经开放，所以现在是申请季，也就是“申请狂热期”。如果你在填写表格方面需要任何支持或指导，请查看我在“Good Thinking Psychological Services”上的YouTube视频。我在今年9月（2021年）做了一系列直播问答视频，去年（2020年）申请季我也做过一些。所以一定要去看看。此外，我是《临床心理学家集体：给有抱负的临床心理学家的建议与指导》（Clinical Psychologist Collective, Advice and Guidance for Aspiring Clinical Psychologists）一书的首席作者。
Collective, Advice and Guidance for Aspiring Clinical Psychologists. So you might not be an aspiring clinical psychologist, you might be be an aspiring clinical psychologist you might be a different sort of aspiring psychologist but my expertise is clinical psychology but of course there is lots of crossover in the things that we are talking about so I hope you will still find this useful and yeah do check out that book and check out those um those youtube videos if you would welcome some guidance from um you know from me but also a collective of um qualified and aspiring psychologists 600 years worth of cumulative experience on offer in those pages. Right, so my clinical specialty is working with trauma, depression, anxiety in adults. But I also do eating disorders work because I do find
你可能不是一名有抱负的临床心理学家，你可能是其他类型的有抱负的心理学家，但我的专长是临床心理学。当然，我们讨论的事情有很多交叉点，所以我希望你仍然会觉得这很有用。一定要去看看那本书，看看那些YouTube视频。如果你欢迎来自我，以及一个由合格和有抱负的心理学家组成的集体提供的指导，那里面汇集了600年的累积经验。好了，我的临床专长是与成人的创伤、抑郁和焦虑症患者合作。但我也会做饮食失调方面的工作，因为我发现……
there is a great deal of crossover with trauma and eating disorders because of the nature of you know control which can be really key post-trauma. Before I was specialising in that and working with adults I worked for four years in a CAMHS service so that's what I did when I first qualified, worked in CAMHS which I loved but I became a mummy for the first time whilst I was working in that service. And it was, you know, 26 miles each way in really, really heavy traffic on the M6. And so a job came up closer to home that was a promotion. And it felt like a bit of a no-brainer, even though it meant moving from my beloved children's services to adults but actually I rose to the challenge and have really really enjoyed it and now would happily call myself you know an adult specialist
创伤和饮食失调之间有很大的交叉，因为控制感在创伤后往往是关键。在专注于此并与成人合作之前，我在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作了四年。那是我刚获得资格时所做的工作，我非常喜欢，但在那期间我第一次成为了妈妈。当时我每天要在M6高速公路上往返26英里，交通非常拥堵。所以离家更近的地方出现了一个晋升机会。尽管这意味着要从我心爱的儿童服务转向成人服务，但这感觉是一个无需多想的选择。实际上，我迎接了挑战，并且非常非常享受，现在我很乐意称自己为成人专家。
but it means I also feel really comfortable in working with young people but currently I am private practice only so in April 2021 so quite new I left the NHS and now work solely in private practice and I only see adults in my in my in my clinic or age 16 and above anyway I don't see any of the younger ones anymore and I am due to the pandemic I am online only but that is likely to continue because it works well for me and it works well for my family I have a great resource that I've created called the our tricky brain kit which is based on compassion-focused therapy theory for helping clients and staff teams to understand the role of trauma and depression on mental health. And I also am the lead author and put together the book, The Grief Collective,
但这并不意味着我不能与年轻人一起工作，只是目前我只做私人执业。2021年4月，也就是不久前，我离开了NHS，现在完全从事私人执业。我的诊所只接待成人，或者16岁及以上的人，我不再接待更小的孩子了。由于疫情，我只在线上工作，但这可能会持续下去，因为它对我个人和我的家庭都很有效。我创建了一个很棒的资源，叫做“我们的棘手大脑工具包”（our tricky brain kit），它基于同情心聚焦疗法（CFT）理论，旨在帮助客户和员工团队理解创伤和抑郁对心理健康的影响。我还是《悲伤集体》（The Grief Collective）一书的首席作者和编纂者。
stories of life, loss and learning to heal heal so if you would welcome learning some more about grief or you um you are grieving yourself then you might really find it useful um to check out um check out that as a resource um it's available in paperback and ebook and i'm working really hard on the ebook of the the Clean Psych Collective being available. So I'm hoping it will be available by the time you are listening to this. But it's not behaving itself at the moment. Right, we're just going to break for a short ad break. And I'll be back with the last part of this first podcast episode very soon. will help you get qualified. So come and take a look.
讲述生活、失去和学习治愈的故事。所以如果你想了解更多关于悲伤的知识，或者你本人正在经历悲伤，你可能会觉得查看那个资源非常有用。它有平装本和电子书版本。我正在努力让《临床心理学家集体》的电子书上线。我希望当你听到这段话时它已经可以购买了，但目前它还在处理中。好了，我们要进入一个简短的广告时间。我很快会回来，带来这第一期播客节目的最后一部分。它将帮助你获得资格。所以来看看吧。
It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAMS service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills but more than that it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfill along the way because the work we do
就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》。我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家CAMHS服务机构担任助理从业者。我购买并阅读了Marianne的书《临床心理学家集体》，以陪伴我完成临床心理学培训申请。事实证明，它确实是一个很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它提供了沉浸在他人故事中的机会。它及时提醒我不要太纠结于最终目标，要珍惜并享受我们一路走来所从事的每一份工作，因为我们所做的工作……
now is important and matters to those we sit alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic routes into clinical psychology which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though because once you've started reading it's tough to put it down. Looking to become a psychologist? Then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book.
现在很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都很重要。它还让我确信，进入临床心理学领域有多种多样的途径，这对我来说很重要，因为我走过弯路，并不是典型的职业路线。我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过要做好准备，暂时放下晚上的任务，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。想成为一名心理学家？那就让这成为你的指南吧。书中充满了将帮助你获得资格的经验教训。所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Hi, welcome back. Thanks for sticking with me. I thought it would be useful to think about some of the upcoming themes that we've got scheduled for our our future podcast episodes so that you know what's coming and you are hopefully you know subscribing to this podcast and telling anyone you think might find it useful but yeah I understand and recall what it's like to be an aspiring psychologist, and it can feel incredibly competitive. So if you want to keep this as your own guilty pleasure, something that's useful, that's okay, too. So we are going to be thinking about using supervision
它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。你好，欢迎回来。感谢你的坚持。我想思考一下我们未来播客节目中计划的一些主题会很有用，这样你就知道接下来会发生什么，并希望你订阅这个播客，告诉任何你认为可能觉得它有用的人。但我理解并记得作为一名有抱负的心理学家的感觉，这可能会让人感到难以置信的竞争。所以如果你想把它当作自己的“罪恶快感”，当作有用的东西，那也没关系。我们将思考如何利用督导……
and supervisory relationship. We're going to be thinking about life events and psychology. We're going to be thinking about, you know, teaching and training. We're going to be thinking about, you know, conducting assessments and our relationships with clients. going to be thinking about issues of diversity and equality, thinking about, you know, research and other kind of ways of evaluating what might be going on within services as well. So this is a really broad brush of the things I'm hoping you guys will find really, really useful. But you know, I do need to know from you what you would like to listen to. I've also got some ideas for thinking about money and financial planning. So yeah, there's lots of cool stuff coming up. And actually, I wanted to put this podcast together because you know it can be really useful to have people that speak your language and hopefully in terms of practicalities I hope this is you can
以及督导关系。我们将思考生活事件与心理学。我们将思考教学与培训。我们将思考如何进行评估以及我们与客户的关系。我们将思考多样性和平等问题，思考研究以及评估服务内部情况的其他方式。所以，我希望你们会觉得这些内容非常非常有用。但我确实需要从你们那里知道你们想听什么。我还有一些关于金钱和财务规划的想法。所以，有很多很酷的内容即将推出。实际上，我想制作这个播客是因为，你知道，有说同样语言的人会非常有用。希望在实用性方面，我希望你能……
understand me clear enough but yeah that's not really what I meant sorry we can be quite tricky with the way we speak can't we sometimes but you, someone that is on your page and kind of is getting you, you know, and the issues that are that are important and pertinent to you right now in order to, you know, progress your career. Because we are a breed, you know, not like many others you know I think our drive certainly my own recollection of my drive to get to where I wanted to be um could be pretty relentless you know and people would be like well I don't get it like well just get a different job or you know stay at Argos and you know go and be a buyer or something else that doesn't light my fire you know I really love this work and so if that is you if that describes you then I am on your page and I am you know so keen to help you advance in your work with people and And I'm gonna be running a free five-day challenge
听得足够清楚。抱歉，我刚才表达得不太准确。我们说话的方式有时确实很棘手，不是吗？但你，一个和你站在同一立场、理解你的人，以及那些对你现在职业发展至关重要的问题。因为我们是一个独特的群体，不像其他许多人。我认为我们的动力，当然我对自己想要达到目标的动力的回忆，可能是相当无情的。人们会说：“我不明白，为什么不换份工作，或者留在Argos，去当个采购员或其他什么不会点燃我激情的工作？”我真的很热爱这份工作。所以，如果这就是你，如果这描述了你，那么我站在你这边，我非常渴望帮助你在与人的工作中取得进步。我将举办一个为期五天的免费挑战……
to further super boost your incredible abilities as an aspiring psychologist. So look out for details about the free five-day challenge, which is coming very soon. And I will get the details to you on how you can register for that as soon as possible but the website address for the holding list for the mailing list is www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk and then forward slash the word aspire a-s-P-I-R-E.
以进一步提升你作为一名有抱负的心理学家的惊人能力。所以请留意关于这个为期五天免费挑战的详细信息，它很快就会到来。我会尽快将如何注册的详细信息发送给你。邮件列表的候补名单网址是 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，然后加上斜杠和单词 aspire (a-s-P-I-R-E)。
And if you check that out, click on the link, you can get yourself on the mailing list for the next free five-day challenge that will continue to run and will be continually updated with the details of when the next challenge is. So I hope you found our first episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast really useful. Please don't be shy.
如果你查看那个链接，点击它，你就可以加入邮件列表，参加下一次免费的五天挑战。该挑战将持续进行，并会不断更新下一次挑战的时间细节。所以我希望你觉得《有抱负的心理学家》播客的第一期非常有用。请不要害羞。
Do let me know if you've got any feedback and rate and review this podcast and subscribe, of course. And I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode next week. Take care. become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Yana, and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist
如果你有任何反馈，请务必告诉我，给这个播客评分、评论并订阅。我期待在下周的下一期节目中与你见面。保重。成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南吧。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Marianne Trent博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Yana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣……
it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be OK. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这让我惊讶于达到目标竟然有这么多不同的途径，成为一名心理学家并没有完美的路径。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始阅读，你就不会放下这本书。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。